hey everybody welcome to metaphysical
milkshake i am of course rayne wilson
and i am of course reza aslan and
hey you know what i've always noticed
about you reza
that i'm like a
persian jake gyllenhaal
maybe more of a maggie
i will totally take that any of the
dylan halls she's fantastic she's more
talented frankly but no it's something
else really you know obviously one of my
my good good friends and sometimes when
we do these podcasts it's it's really
almost like you're the other half of my
brain
oh
tell me more yeah you are you you know
you say the things that i'm thinking we
finish each other's sentences it's like
it's like we share the same share the
same brain yeah we should oh how did you
know i was gonna say that weird that was
weird
you know what now that you mentioned it
actually i think i know what you're
talking about i sort of feel it too
there are these weird times where i feel
like
i don't know where my mind stops and
yours begins welcome to metaphysical
milkshake the show where we go deep we
get weird and we search for the meaning
of life along the way presented by cast
media and soul pancake
[Music]
okay actually this is quite a
fascinating topic because right it's
becoming more and more apparent
throughout you know science and you know
all the sort of cognitive developments
that are taking place all around us that
this whole process of thinking isn't
necessarily confined to the skull
maybe the mind is actually a kind of
massive network that extends throughout
the body that extends beyond the body
that kind of touches upon space and
other people what i'm trying to say rain
is maybe our brains our minds are
actually touching each other
that's
gross
but deep so what you're saying is that
when the mind is bigger than just one's
head
exactly oh my god reza you know what
that means
what does it mean we're brain besties
for life
brain besties for life
and to help us have a further
conversation about being brain besties
we have the foremost expert on the topic
her name is annie murphy paul her new
book the extended mind the power of
thinking outside the brain
beautifully elucidates the topic yeah
annie is a former senior editor at
psychology today so she clearly knows
what she's talking about
she's got a ton of awards her writing
has appeared in the new york times
magazine new york times book review
slate discover health oh the oprah
magazine she's also the author of
origins how the nine months before birth
shaped the rest of our lives and this is
actually one of our bigger books the
cult of personality how personality
tests are leading us to mis-educate our
children mismanage our companies and
misunderstand ourselves how about that
subtitle there rain that's a long
subtitle a long beautiful alliterative
subtitle
eddie murphy paul welcome to the show
thank you guys i'm really glad to be
here the extended mind look if you're
watching on youtube i'm showcasing this
beautiful book and it's gorgeous cover
really i like this cover it is like a
rainbow threw up on the cover of your
book it's fantastic
it's rainbow barf that's exactly what it
looks like you're right people keep
asking me if the book is about drugs and
drug experience which i i think i think
the graphic on the cover has something
to do with that it looks a little
psychedelic it's a little ayahuasca a
little bit
the book is actually about something
kind of
uh you know
druggy which is about this notion about
you know
where does the mind actually reside and
maybe the brain isn't this magical organ
that it's been kind of set up to be in
our sort of popular imagination so yes
and so that is a little trippy yeah
i can see where people are coming from
yeah so to get us started what are some
of the dominant myths about the mind and
what and why do we need to understand
how
we think
yeah i think that the the main myth
about the brain that this book is
seeking to address and to counter is
that the brain is this
all-powerful all-purpose thinking
machine
um and that
we can use it to
tackle all of the most
complicated and difficult questions and
and problems in modern life it doesn't
need any help it's this you know
extraordinary amazing organ that is um
the most complicated object in the
universe you know these are all the
things we hear from popular science
accounts of the brain yeah
so what this book sets out to
argue is that the brain is it's an it's
a
quirky idiosyncratic very limited
biological organ that evolved to do jobs
that are very different from what we ask
it to do today and so it actually needs
all the help it can get in terms of
what i call in the book extraneural
resources meaning outside the brain
resources which could be
our technologies and tools it could be
our bodies it could be physical space it
could be the minds of other people all
of these things
can be considered part of the thinking
process and in fact should be
intentionally drawn into the thinking
process if we want to think well see
this is exactly the reason that we
wanted you on this program because i i
think this is so fascinating because
you're right
we especially you know in the modern
world have been raised to think of the
brain as like this machine this super
computer right you said it perfectly
it's the most complex system
in the universe right the most
complicated most sophisticated computer
that we have has nothing on the brain
and
what do we what are we always told like
we we use 10 of our brain so
we don't even understand it it's a
mystery right that's right that's the
elevated status that the brain has and
you're basically like well no i mean
it's kind of it's like basically an
organ right it's like it's like your
gallbladder it's a little bit more
complicated than your gallbladder yeah
and
don't our brains fail us all the time
you know that's the paradox that comes
at me when i see these popular science
depictions of the brain like
you end up thinking did i just get a bum
one did is mine a dud you know because i
forget things all the time i i get
confused all the time where's that
amazing extraordinary organ well
actually that's just a reflection of the
universal limits of the brain and that's
why
we need to um to rely on these outside
the brain resources you use a lot of
metaphors in the book and a central
metaphor that you challenge is the one
we're talking about right now what is
the main problem with the brain as
computer metaphor mm-hmm
yeah so this is a a
analogy that arose in in the middle of
the last century during the cognitive
revolution and it really i mean once you
start noticing it it permeates our
understanding of the brain even just our
everyday uh let the everyday language we
use to talk about the brain we talk
about bandwidth we talk about mental you
know processing speed and um we really
do think of our brains as a computer and
that's a really
misleading meta and limiting
constraining metaphor for so many
reasons i mean for one thing brain uh
computers don't have bodies and we are
very much embodied creatures and
the body is an integral part of our
thinking processes a computer works
exactly the same no matter where it's
located whereas the human brain is
exquisitely sensitive to context to
where it's doing its thinking and brains
i mean sorry computers don't have
friends you know they don't have
colleagues they they don't um they
network with other computers but they're
not affected by
um
others of their kind the way humans are
so profoundly affected by other people
and um
so in all these ways the the brain is
computer metaphor just really it
undersells us humans um it it kind of um
encourages it encourages us to cut
ourselves off from what are actually the
wellsprings of our human intelligence
which is the fact that we are embodied
creatures who are embedded in physical
spaces and involved engaged in these
social networks that that's where a lot
of our
specifically human intelligence comes
from so when we think of ourselves as
computers we really are selling
ourselves short
first of all uh i i just like i feel so
sad thinking about all those lonely
computers with no friends no we don't
have friends just like
you know
i would say that there's even a sort of
a bigger uh metaphor that is often used
for the brain uh yeah we've all heard
the brain as the computer thing that's
very much like a result of the cognitive
uh revolution but the other kind of
result of that is this notion that the
brain is everything that it's the seat
of everything right and
it's that all experiences
your very sense of self who you are what
we would call consciousness
the you know soul mind whatever um
everything that you experience in the
world all of it
is just
the result of chemical reactions in the
brain that in a sense you don't even
really need the body anymore like all
those sort of futuristic science science
fiction movies where we're all just like
brains in jars like because that's
really where we are
right nothing
we're told we're told that
the reason we can see is not because of
our eyes but because our brains the
reason that we can taste something is
not because of our tongue but because of
our brains so like
the brain
is who we are
and so in a sense all of that kind of
starts crumbling when you start thinking
about this
the way that you're talking about the
brain which is like the brain in
dialogue and conversation with the body
that it actually can't just be
uh an organ inside of a you know a vat
of fluid uh just floating around without
us
right like the matrix right we're not
we're not living in the matrix as far as
we know as far as we know yeah oh
contraire i'm sorry but you know that's
another episode so we'll get to that
later
fair enough but all of that is wrong
which i i think is is really fascinating
because that's definitely how i think
in fact the the very topic of this of
this episode
you know is the is i think therefore i
am uh and it goes all the way back to
you know that a fundamental uh uh
question posed by descartes right this
notion of uh kogito ergosome what does
it mean
to be
and the way we know we are is because
our brains are thinking
and it's kind of what
what we've been taught it's i feel like
it's what i was taught at school
and so it's a it's a
pardon the pun but mind expanding thing
to suddenly think
that no the brain is just kind of one
element
and maybe not even the the most dominant
element but probably
um in the process of thinking and
therefore consciousness and therefore
knowledge of the world and knowledge of
the self and all of those things
yeah i make the argument i mean speaking
of i think therefore i am i make the
argument in the chapter in the book
about intraoception this this capacity
we have to sense
all these signals and cues arising from
within our body that uh it's actually
the continuous sense of um
this internal world in the body um the
fact that we you know we can feel our
lungs expanding we can feed some of us
can feel our hearts beating some of us
are not so good at that but we um we
inhabit this body
in a continual
a continuous and and such an intimate
way throughout our lives and that really
is what gives us the sense that i am
this person and no other i'm the same
person i was two weeks ago or 20 years
ago um and to locate that sense of
self in the brain is actually um perhaps
misguided as common as it is as you've
been saying
folks is your company or business having
a tough time hiring the people you need
i mean we keep hearing this all the time
you watch the news everybody's having
difficulty
hiring and you know it's it's difficult
because right now we're at this place
where there are something like 46 more
jobs being posted than before the
pandemic and believe it or not there are
44
fewer candidates applying to each one of
those jobs
so
in that kind of environment you need to
find the right candidate and you need to
hire them fast and that's where workable
comes in workable accelerates every step
of your hiring process from find to
higher it helps you cast the widest net
possible by posting your jobs to all of
the top job boards more than 200 total
with just a single click it helps you
evaluate and hire quickly with modern
tools like video interviews and
e-signatures
and workable will help you automate
repetitive tasks like scheduling
interviews so you can spend your time
you know making hires
so whether you're hiring for your coffee
shop or your engineering team workable
is exactly what you need to hire the
right people fast it's a crazy time and
so many indicators show that the economy
is better than it's ever been
um now we've got inflation however we've
got the oil and gas crisis
happening there's so much uncertainty
out there you need all the help you can
get in your hiring
help search over
job boards with workable start hiring
today with a risk-free 15-day trial if
you hire during the trial which many
many do
it won't cost a thing just go to
workable.com to start hiring workable is
hiring made easy
you say in your book
instead of thinking of the brain as a
workhorse we keep flogging to get the
job done think of the brain as an
orchestra conductor
the brain is central to thinking but
it's not doing all the work on its own
this is kind of the thesis of the
extended mind you know and it reminds us
uh rez and i were talking earlier about
the humble octopus
the philosopher peter godfrey smith
wrote the octopus lives outside the
usual body brain divide
and the nervous system as a whole
is a more relevant object than the brain
it's not clear where the brain begins
and ends and when the nervous system
runs through
the body the octopus is suffused with
nervousness the body is not a separate
thing that is controlled by the brain or
by the nervous system so
are we like an octopus or what can we
learn from an octopus
oh gosh i just over the break finally
saw my octopus teacher which maybe you
guys yeah it was so so beautiful um i do
think we are more like uh i think we're
not supposed to say octopi right
no believe it or not it's octopusses
which i thought it was octopode oh
that's
yeah
or octopodi
octopode yeah we're more like those
those eight they have eight arms right
eight armed creatures than we um
yeah i mean and that's part of that that
whole
cartesian duality of mind being separate
from
from body i think is was in part an
effort to separate us and and
distinguish us from animals actually and
and what i want to say in this book is
that we're more like animals like
non-human animals than we are like
machines and yet um we so persistently
analogize ourselves to machines i think
because
with a computer we imagine an idealized
version of ourselves with all the messy
embarrassing inconvenient parts of being
a human sort of engineered out but when
we do that when we engineer out these as
i say these wellsprings of human
intelligence we actually end up with a
different kind of intelligence and i
would say an inferior kind of
intelligence so it's really embracing
our animal nature our embodied nature
that i think is the path to really
to true intelligence and are you talking
about our gut instinct because people
talk about like oh my gut says this and
i know that scientists are talking about
the gut as like a second brain
yeah do you feel like that yes you know
i feel it in my gut and that the gut
really helps works alongside the brain
what have you learned about that yeah
you know i i don't get into the um
the gut
the literal gut as a kind of um
itself
an organ that can that contributes to
cognition although i know there is there
is research um looking into that i'm i'm
talking more about you know gut instinct
is a colloquial phrase that reflects our
sense
that and it's an accurate sense that um
the body is intimately involved in in
our thinking processes and and as i
mentioned there's this process called
intraoception which um
is
one of the ways in which the body alerts
us to all the things we know
on a non-conscious level but that
you know there's far too much
information that we encounter
uh every day in order
uh
for us to consciously process and store
and remember all of that but we do
store and process and store that on a
non-conscious level so then
the question is how do we get access to
that information that we that we do
possess and the answer is that the it's
the body that alerts us to to
regularities um that we're seeing in in
um
in our environment to patterns that
we've encountered before it's the body
with those you know
little twinges and
feelings of tension or um excitement or
fear that are sort of tapping us on the
shoulder or tugging us on the sleeve and
saying pay attention you've seen this
before you know you you have the body is
preparing us to take on that challenge
but all of that happens below awareness
and so we don't count it as thinking but
it's actually um
really a very consequential part of
thinking we identify ourselves with our
conscious minds but so much of mental
activity happens below consciousness
this is such a fascinating conversation
um but if i were to be perfectly honest
i'm less interested
in the science than i am in the
metaphysics of it
let's get metaphysical as we like to say
the question for me has much more to do
with the mind than the brain right
you know we we think of these two things
as separate and i think it's you know
your book is called the extended mind
because it's deliberately trying to sort
of take the idea of what the mind is
outside of the brain i feel like so much
of contemporary science
which is very brain focused you know
is centered on this idea that whatever
the mind is that it's actually located
in the brain right that there isn't
really
a difference between the two but that
certainly isn't what you're
writing about here so
i guess the first the first part of this
question i got like we've got like seven
steps to this question here but the
first part of it is
if the mind isn't actually located
in the brain then
where does it reside is it the penis is
it the penis just let us know
annie is it why would you go why do you
have to go there well i just feel like
it might be
what if you don't have one then
you know
deep i of course as a man never thought
about it
yeah perhaps i should pass on that
question this is a
profound
and elemental question right because
for a lot of people
the mind and the soul
are synonymous
right that sometimes we we talk about
the mind as the seed of consciousness
the the the seed of our essence but
that's how we talk about the soul right
spiritual people talk about the soul
very much in the same way
and this idea that the mind is just a
thing that exists in the brain
is oftentimes not always but oftentimes
used to pull the rug out from underneath
uh you know more kind of spiritual
metaphysically minded people who talk
about the mind and the seed of essence
and people are like you're stupid the
mind is the brain
but this new way of thinking about what
the mind is
and of course all the implications that
come from the idea of what the mind
could be what does it say about
us as human beings to to divorce mind
from brain the way that you do in this
book
or to say that mind is bigger than brain
yeah i should say maybe we should have
said this sort of said this earlier that
the extended mind is an idea that i
borrowed i did not make up this idea it
borrowed from two philosophers andy
clark and david chalmers and
their 1998
we couldn't get them annie so
they weren't they were busy tonight i
know um so i'm here in their stead um
they their article introducing this idea
of the extended mind they have a
beautiful first sentence in that article
which said
where does the mind
stop and the rest of the world begin
and they acknowledge that the
conventional answer to that
is that the mind and the brain are are
identical that the mind stops at the
skull
and their argument was that no actually
the mind our thinking processes extend
out beyond the skull into the rest of
our bodies into physical space into
our our tools and technologies into the
minds of other people and clark and
chalmers have their own
standards for when a tool for example a
notebook or a smartphone can be counted
as an extension of the brain you know
they think it needs to be reliably
coupled with um with with our thinking
process in such a way that the that loop
is really um
very consistent and reliable and and um
uh continuous and i you know i those to
me are questions for philosophers i'm
more interested in
um almost operationalizing this this
idea i felt like it was too good of an
idea to generative of an idea to leave
to the philosophers i wanted to know
okay so if the if the
mind extends beyond the skull what does
that mean for our daily
activities of thinking and learning and
creating and
it turns out there are there are these
bodies of research
that have been
developing emerging for the last 20 or
30 years like embodied cognition the
idea that we think with our bodies
situated cognition the idea that where
we are affects how we think and socially
distributed cognition the idea that um
thinking doesn't only happen in
individual heads and of course the idea
that mind equals brain is a very
individualistic idea you know that it
all it's all this lump of of stuff
inside your head that it determines how
well you think and so once we you know
residue asked like what is it
what are the implications for how we
understand ourselves as as human beings
um
if we were to take the extended the
thesis of the extended mind seriously
and
you know clark and chalmers said in that
original articles it would lead us to
see ourselves more truly as creatures of
the world we're really constituted by
the world by our relationships by our
physical environment and so to me that's
a pretty profound rethinking of of what
a human being is so the the answer to
that question
where does the mind
end
fundamentally if if it's about context
and the idea that the mind takes
elements from you know uh around us um
you know that it's all about you know uh
relationship to the world well then the
answer is them it it doesn't
where does the mind end it doesn't
potentially no right i know this isn't
necessarily your field of study but
isn't there like reza's kind of hinting
at kind of some spiritual implications
because you know i practice
meditation and i meditate every day and
i read a lot of like vedic
kind of and buddhist thought which kind
of tells us in a you know purely
spiritual sense that
the we're in an illusion that we're
separate the illusion of separateness
that we're we are
interconnected
um
just as nature is interconnected you use
the orchestra uh metaphor a lot
throughout the book that there is
that you know where i stop and where you
begin it's it's all it's all blurry
light consciousness
and i know this is sounding very airy
fairy right now no it's good stuff but
when i
when i go there my life is richer
my life is happier and i'm more
satisfied and then when i am thinking of
myself as you know i am paul simon i am
a rock i'm an island i am a brain in a
brain case so there are there are
tangible
implications as well as metaphysical
implications because meditation and
thinking of myself as all one all
connected
uh makes my life better how has this
research how is this work around the
extended mind
improved your life in specific ways
well it's so interesting that you say
that rain because um a number of people
have said to me i've noted that the book
has a kind of buddhist flavor which is
interesting was striking to me because
there's nothing about buddhism in the
book but i am myself very interested in
buddhism i meditate i read a lot about
buddhism and and i couldn't help but see
you know it's not that the work on my
work on the extended mind led me to
buddhism but clearly they have some
common themes that were that drew me to
both of them i've said that writers
really they often write what they need
to learn and despite my buddhist
leanings or maybe that's all related in
some way um
i would i would say i'm a very i started
this project as a very brain bound
person brain bound is the word another
word that i borrowed from andy clark i
got that i like i i love that i the
concept of brain bound thinking which
you talk about in the book a lot of
times right
so you know i'm a freelance writer
i work alone and
you know um i mostly don't move
during the day i'm doing all the things
that i say not to do in the book when i
talk about bringing movement and gesture
and social interaction and you know
changing your environment and all that i
didn't you know i i was not someone who
did any of that and so i think in some
ways
the journey of writing this book really
um i really had to convince myself first
and foremost that there was something to
this idea that
everything doesn't happen inside the
head and ideally should not happen
inside the head that we think more
efficiently and more effectively when we
externalize our cognition when we um
offload as much of it as possible but it
can be a frightening idea to to people
i've noticed that people
push back against that idea sometimes
because they like the idea that they own
their intelligence they own their
their own accomplishments that they're
not um attributable to anyone or
anything outside themselves um so it's
it's not a
it's a bit of a counter-cultural kind of
idea i think it goes against the grain
yeah it's uh it's anti-individualistic
um
you know this idea that um
you know we have to sort of
think beyond our brain bound existence
that
uh whatever you know if you do really
think of the mind as the sort of seed of
your essence the the core of your
consciousness which is after all
how we understand who we are and our
role in the world if you understand the
mind as
uh necessarily in communication
with
not just your body but with all the
external stimuli
and so therefore
you know we are
actively engaged with one another and
with nature
and that's
that is
literally how we think it's how you know
our our mind functions yeah those can be
scary ideas
right
it's like you're not in control of
yourself anymore right right control of
the eye so it go it's going back to
descartes right what does it mean to be
right his idea was so individualistic
and and so brain bound right how do i
know i am because i am thinking
but if in thinking yeah but if thinking
isn't a thing that happens in inside
your skull
if thinking is a thing that happens
you know
in this dialectic between
uh you know your brain and your body and
your body and everybody else's body then
there's this sort of collectiveness to
the experience of being
which on the one hand is beautiful the
way that rain was talking about it right
this idea that the whole point of
meditation is to sort of go beyond
yourself and to understand the oneness
of all being but it's also weird and
foreign and you know
scary a little bit and yeah doesn't
sound like something jesus would say
which right away
you know makes me somewhat skeptical
i hear it let me let me let me quote
another guru reign you may appreciate
this um rahm das used to say you're not
who you think you are and i think that's
the challenge posed by
the extended mind you're not who you
think you are you're not this individual
bound brain bound
um
discrete creature cut off from
everything the boundary between you and
the world is actually quite blurry and
hard to
hard to determine and i think it takes
time to become comfortable with that
idea well
you know along those lines uh
you know this whole concept i think
therefore i am but really our
consciousness lies in oh i witness
myself thinking therefore i am there's a
there's another level above thought
which is noticing yourself
having a thought
and so there and there's greater and
greater levels of consciousness that can
be ascribed yeah or even that thoughts
think themselves and there's no self or
no i there doing the thinking you talk
about a lot of different ways
that the mind works ways that we think
ponder process ideate you know
neural architecture you know how our
design around us affects our thinking
you know moving versus sitting down that
we we learn by being in our bodies were
you talking about that with your kids
reza well you know we're back at
distance learning here and uh and you
know my poor kids are sitting you know
at their desk staring at a screen
and you know they're they're fidgeting
and they're getting up and i'm
constantly yelling at them to sit back
down and and and quote-unquote think and
now i'm reading your book and it's like
no that's not a good idea you should not
be sitting when you think but but going
off of that too you also talk about
social thinking and consultation like
thinking in groups as opposed to kind of
thinking in a brain bound isolation you
say our brains evolve to think with
people to teach them to argue with them
exchange stories human thought is
sensitive to context and one of the most
powerful contexts is the presence of
other people we often think differently
and better
than when we think non-socially can you
talk about
social thinking
yeah sure and i'll talk about that in
the context of just what reza was saying
that i think the pandemic has actually
been this vast natural experiment that
has shown us the limitations of brain
bound thinking you know for two years
we've been brains in front of screens
and i think we've felt the the
difference you know and
we're punching people on airplanes right
and left
you don't have any nuts
we've been cut off from many of the
mental extensions that in normal times
really help us to think like
stimulating new places and um in-person
interaction with other people and the
freedom to move our bodies around
instead of just sitting in front of our
screens and trying to get stuff done um
so that and that social piece reign i
think is really key that really gets it
really pushes against this uh assumption
of individualism that's built into our
culture and um
i i i'm struck again and again by how
much we seem to
just as we separate the mind from the
body uh
traditionally we we tend to separate
intellectual life mental life from
social life as if they're different and
separate and maybe even opposed to each
other you know we we work all day and
then we go for a happy hour after work
or we expect kids to sit still in the
classroom but then you can you can talk
at lunch or recess or something but
human beings
we are such fundamentally and powerfully
social creatures and we're social
creatures all the time that doesn't get
turned off when we're in the workplace
or in the classroom so then the
challenge becomes how do we harness
these incredibly powerful social brains
that we have in the service of learning
and working instead of trying to
separate the two and shut one off and
it's so hard for people to ask for help
and for people to consult and use kind
of the greater wisdom of you know i've
taken in the last
you know
decade or so to really rely on my
friends and and groups to
you know help me out of pickles and and
help guide me on certain paths and seek
direction and it's so hard especially
for males that's another
i think females are are naturally a
little bit more kind of socially
connected uh that's another conversation
but rain is my only friend oh and i'm
happy to guide you and direct you reza
which is to quit this podcast
once and for all but you know it's hard
for men to reach out and say hey what
should i do how can you know here's my
issues here's my my mode of thinking and
i'm going around and around and in this
mode of thinking in an ocd way help me
out of it help guide me but we you we
really
through that process of social
interaction and consultation guidance
wisdom which we used to have as people
we used to be in tribes that's what we
did around with the chiefs and the
shamans around the fire we would seek
seek guidance and you know and make
decisions communally yeah yeah and
that's about creating
those cog these cognitive loops that
seem to improve human thinking in a way
that has no analog with computers i'm
going to quote andy clark again he says
humans are intrinsically loopy creatures
there's something about the nature of
our own biological intelligence that um
is enhanced by
looping thoughts out of our heads and
through our bodies you know through our
physical spaces through the minds of
other people and
again and again you know and and if as
long as we keep our thoughts inside our
own heads they can't get enhanced and
improved that way
so we can learn to um to create those
cognitive loops but it's not it's not um
it's not what our culture prescribes
now that we have firmly established that
descartes was some french bastard
who would yeah we should stop reading in
college
um
fundamentally and i know this is not
what your book is really about your book
is you know deeply about the science and
the implications of the science but
on a on a sort of more metaphysical and
spiritual level fundamentally
at the end of the day who are we
if we are not
our brains you know yeah who are we dad
yeah well this this perspective if we're
going to take it seriously puts
such enormous uh emphasis
on the quality of our environments right
i mean literally the raw these are the
raw materials with which we're
constructing our thought and none of
that really matters if it's all due to
this lump of stuff in our heads but once
we start thinking of you know you we
were talking earlier about metaphors and
another metaphor that i i
came up with and i really like and so
i'm going to mention here is that our
brains are like magpies those birds that
collect shiny bits of and pieces from
their environment and weave them into
their nests and that's really
what our thinking process is like more
than this workhorse you know or this or
this muscle that's another very common
metaphor in our culture that the brain
is like a muscle uh the the brain i
think is really more like um
it
the brain does its thinking by
assembling
raw materials from our our physical
sensations our physical environment our
relationships with other people and then
weaving them into our thought process so
if that's the case then what's all
around us and in us in our bodies and
how well we pay attention to that and
make use of that um really matters and
so it's it's a very it's a deeply
ecological kind of perspective on a
human nature
so annie murphy paul
one thing we like to do and how we wrap
up our conversations is a lightning
round we're gonna we're gonna throw out
some of life's greatest and most
challenging
questions to you and in the blink of an
eye you're going to respond
uh and we would love to hear you respond
not from your brain
but from your octopus gut
so we're going to hit you with some big
ones ready so what is something that few
people know about you
not that many people know that i am a
buddhist that's been a kind of i just
haven't really you're a closet buddhist
you're coming out of the closet
congratulations yes i am or i'm coming
home is there a closet
is it all one big room
what skill do you wish you had
oh gosh i'm not really good at
logistical things and keeping on top of
things i just like to think about big
ideas so it would be nice if i were a
little more
attuned to the
practicalities of daily life
if you could interview any person living
or dead who would it be i you know as
much as
psychoanalysis has been
vilified and attacked i still think it
it
it contains so many insights about human
nature i would love to interview freud
freud wow
what's the first question you would ask
him
did you ever figure out what women
wanted
[Laughter]
famously famously wrong about literally
everything
um what happens to us after we die annie
uh we we
go back to the earth and become part of
the soil
and and and hopefully you know allow
more things to grow
uh i think that's what i believe that's
it consciousness it just turns out like
a light bulb
i think i i think the buddhist in you is
debating the scientist
i'm not sure but i think there's a kind
of there's a way in which we
we continue to be part of the fabric of
of the earth of the universe but just in
a different form and i don't mean
reincarnation i just mean um
we go you know from dust to dust i think
maybe that's my i was raised a catholic
so um there's probably a little bit of
that still hanging around
when do you feel most connected with the
universe
i know i should say when i'm outside in
nature but i'm actually more of an
indoors kind of person
uh i love
i love conversation so when you're binge
watching
yes
exactly
i love connecting with other people on a
deep level and really really good
conversations you know like this one
we're having right here no that i really
think that that's probably when i
certainly when i feel most alive and
most authentic
speaking of uh
conversations delightful conversations
uh if you could have coffee with 19 year
old annie murphy paul what would you
tell her oh gosh i would say
interestingly you know i would say don't
be so afraid of people because this this
love of connection and this ease of
being with people that i feel now that
i'm 49 so this would be this would be 30
years ago um
uh this would be that the self that i'm
talking to would be 30 years ago um i
was quite shy and socially inhibited and
afraid actually reign afraid of asking
for help
and
i would have been i guess a
freshman or sophomore in college and i i
really felt like
this was a very individual undertaking
you know this this academic um
achievement path of achievement that i
felt i was on and i really
wish i had
um been able to feel
that i could really be myself with with
those i knew at the time but that just
took a really long time to
develop
final lightning round question the one
we ask everyone
um what is your
life's big question well this is one i
think about all the time i would have
said that my life's big question is what
makes us the way we are and a lot of my
the work that i did earlier in my career
or earlier books and magazine articles
were very much trying to get my arms
around that question i've recently
become more interested in
how do we change i think maybe that's
like a midlife question it's like okay i
am who i am i become myself but now i
want to change into something else you
know so i'm in i'm interested in those
questions of identity in the sense of
who are we as individuals and how did we
get to be that way i'm very interested
in the nurture nature question and then
the interplay of um
of innate factors and environmental
factors so that would that would be the
big question well i believe we have an
entire podcast episode on that uh you
should uh subscribe and
like
can we change can we change our minds
can we change uh who we are who who who
do you interview for that is it just or
is it the two of you talking adam grant
touched on that and like how we can
change people's minds that was that was
a fun conversation oh yes
right right andy murphy paul thank you
so much for joining us the book is
called the extended mind fascinating i
mean the science is interesting your
writing is wonderful but just the
the questions that it brings up about
what it means to be human uh i think are
just
incredibly enlightening thank you so
much for joining us thank you thank you
this conversation has made me feel
really connected to the universe
it has it's been a pleasure it really
has fantastic thanks for coming on the
show
here's what i find
absolutely fascinating about that
conversation with andy murphy paul
and i love her name and i feel like i
need to say all three elements of her
name
all the time
this idea that like
we are really
nothing without
our environment and our context right we
this is kind of where we ended the
conversation about this idea that like
you know mind extends beyond the brain
it actually extends beyond the body that
what we consider to be mind and then
therefore the seed of consciousness is
in constant dialogue with environment
that means that whatever we are
however we
understand even the question what am i
can't be answered in isolation that we
we are
intimately connected to each other we
are indivisible
from
nature and the world and therefore the
universe which by the way
is what you know the most basic laws of
science tell us right that you know all
matter
is the same all matter is eternal i'm
made of stars
uh but to think that our consciousness
that's what deepak chopra says
that's what deepak chopra says yeah
we're startups he gets more money for
saying it than i do yes he does he has
paid millions you know what i'm saying
like am i am i deepak chopraing you here
no this is probably our you and i the
thing one of the things we share in
total common is our favorite question is
this hard question of consciousness and
this the experience of consciousness of
feelings thoughts memories sensations
also thoughts pondering small thoughts
like where did i leave my car keys but
large thoughts like what is the meaning
of it all or how do i take in beauty
like this consciousness you know
certainly there's parts of it that are
connected to what i would call a brain
and certainly there are parts of it that
are the mind but you know consciousness
can be expanded and i'm not talking
about through drugs although that i
guess can help people but there are
non-drug ways to expand
one's consciousness but i love
this idea of like here we are where
these where these sweaty farty
fleshy creatures and we've got this big
gray matter riding around in a skull and
we certainly have a mind and we can you
know
articulate and pontificate and we can
you know circumnamulate and ponder but
our consciousness is is is even greater
than that but i love the
just the the mystery of it all is just
fantastic and it is simply not reducible
to
those are all an illusion caused by
neural synapses in your brain firing
away of that sensation
of being alive yeah you know ancient
peoples paleolithic peoples believed
that
that you know we all
share a single
essence like the tree the rock you know
the sky
the wind and me that it's all
fundamentally the same
and it's so crazy how like you know 200
000 years
later we are just kind of slowly coming
back to that very real reality right
that what i am
is
indivisible
from what you are well you know the
ancient egyptians would uh
when they mummified people there's no
brains in mummies they would throw out
the brains they had no idea what a brain
did they had a very
apparently uh
deep knowledge of what all the organs
were responsible for like
where thinking happened which was in the
gut by the way and feeling and anger and
envy and and whatnot but brains they
were like i don't know what the hell
this thing is just this juicy wet sponge
that had to be removed forcibly through
the nose you know and if there's if if
we needed any further proof and this was
something i was going to potentially
bring up in the interview but in my
research there's this incredible case
his name is noah wall
and it's a little boy in england and he
was born with only two percent of his
brain
and survival and thinking was thought to
be impossible for this kitty only two
percent of his brain reza he did not
have a cerebral cortex
which is considered the seat of
consciousness itself and his brain grew
and he's functioning almost in the
normal range and he talks at age level
and you can look him up just look up
noah wall it's absolutely incredible and
it counters everything science has been
saying about the brain the mind and
consciousness
as usual when you rate and review us on
apple podcasts you might get to come on
our show and ask us your life's big
question and today we have a fan special
guest named sam and he's from utah hi
sam from utah hello what is your life's
big question the question i came up with
and it's kind of multifaceted and and
this is actually great for you because
you're both fathers i just had a baby
three months ago oh my first one
do you have a you have a womb
rain
and
um uh i just wanted to know like the big
question is
if
in this scenario giving advice as more
experienced fathers
to someone who's just becoming a father
what do you think is the most important
thing you could pass on
and and part of that
um just like from my perspective i feel
kind of overwhelmed
by
the fact that i could mess this kid up
and and i feel like the world is
contentious and i want to be i want to
be a good dad and i want to be able to
and the thing i appreciate from both of
you
um and like rain i've read uh bassoon
king
um so
being able to transfer my faith
and my
like my beliefs and my spirituality into
my son is also important
so i'm just wondering so the question is
like what would be the best piece of
advice you could give a new father oh
that's a that's a good one you know what
i'm going to swiftly pass you over the
guy with 17 children
i am i am a terrible father i'm just
true
true i have seen you with walt you're a
great daughter i don't listen i just
lecture
um
a lot of physical corporal punishment
physical discipline
um folks please don't
call tmz none of this is true all right
well reza what what do you think
fundamentally
all
a kid wants is attention
all a child needs is for you to be
staring straight at them and just giving
them
time and energy like all the
developmental psychology that my wife
forced me to read
all basically boils down to that give
your child attention just simple as that
that's all they need it's all they want
it's how they develop their brains it's
how they understand empathy and and you
know all the things that you want from
them right
but i will say one thing
that
i've been thinking about a lot recently
because rain and i have been talking
online offline about consciousness what
is consciousness you know how does it
function and
and i don't know right if you agree with
me on this but like
the the one thing that's
the sort of weirdest experience about
having children
is that
for the first time
it changes
your
experience of consciousness all right
let me let me explain what i mean by
this like
if you if you think of consciousness at
its most basic level
as
uh awareness of the self
okay that's a lot of other things but
let's just like strip it down to its
most basic level
i am aware of myself and my existence
it's kind of like a bubble that i live
inside of
having kids
it it
it does this weird thing where it like
expands the bubble
the bubble gets like bigger and other
people fit into it
you know like your wife no matter how
close you are your wife is a different
being and separate from you so she's
never in that bubble but suddenly like
this child this like piece of you enters
that bubble and like your consciousness
at least for the first
couple of years i think of of parenthood
suddenly expands and there's this other
person in it like you see the world
through
their eyes and their experiences like it
expands your
knowledge of self
your self-awareness becomes bigger and
it's the craziest thing it's
it's spiritual it's
psychological it's metaphysical it's all
of those things but it's there's a lot
of ways to talk about what changes in
you when you have a child
you know you're more this you're less
that whatever
but like
at a existential level
it's the first time that your
consciousness makes room
for another entity
you know what am i just making am i
making sense at all rain does that make
sense i don't i don't understand what
the hell you're talking about reza
but i will say this i barely have i just
want to say i barely understand what i'm
talking about having a child uh is a
paradigm shift it really shifts what
it's like to be in the world you know
before you have children it's just like
you know where am i gonna eat
when am i gonna poop
what movie am i gonna watch tonight
that's kind of your life and then you
have children all of a sudden you have a
little life
um that you're responsible for but
speaking of consciousness an interesting
thing about consciousness and we don't
really talk about this is how it evolves
because
does a baby have consciousness sure of
course it does you know it sees light
and color and hears sound has sensation
does a three-year-old have it well yeah
a little bit more does a seven-year-old
have it yeah they're able to you know
add and subtract and they're able to use
the alphabet and remember things and
have tasks and errands as a 12 year old
and now like my son is 17 and like i'll
start to say walter remember and he'll
like finish my sentence and tell a joke
and be three steps ahead of me and it's
like all of a sudden i'm realizing like
whoa his consciousness is at an adult
level now and that and that is a
miraculous thing is that you're helping
build someone's consciousness you're
you're a part of that
evolution it's going to evolve with or
without you but you're aiding the
development of that child's
consciousness that's pretty cool
but here's another thing i want to throw
into the mix sam
i think i've brought this up before on
the show at some point in time but i
just love it in the baha'i faith my
religious tradition uh the son of the
founder of the baha'i faith said in a in
a longer uh kind of tablet he said let
your children become accustomed to
hardship
and i think that's a really interesting
challenge
because we want to take away all the
pain and we want to take away all the
difficulty right and certainly that
doesn't mean like allow your children to
feel unnecessary pain and
and difficulty but
the light you're gonna best prepare them
for life by have them unders having them
understand that there's gonna be
disappointment there's gonna be skinned
knees
there's gonna be uh difficulties there's
gonna be rejection there's going to be
some kind of like bullying happening um
not a you know crazy bullying but
there's people are going to be mean
sometimes and people are going to be
unpredictable you're not going to
control so
letting your children become accustomed
to the difficulties of the world is
actually doing them a tremendous favor
and i do think that contemporary
parenting tries to erase all of that
yeah and then you have these kids in
college and in their first job
resilience yeah no resilience exactly no
grit no determination um and uh they
just get knocked down by some very
simple obstacles i actually see that i
teach um at a private school
right now a k-12 school and i see that a
lot with uh
the current youth
that there's there's a lot of issues and
things that i didn't have to deal with
but there's a lot of things that even
and i'm you know one you've got even
more experience than i do but i just
think i was
a lot tougher
in school for a lot of things that for
them it's just impossible
and so
and but i also feel like and and i
haven't studied parenting books but i do
feel the need to like
sue them every time he cries and so try
to figure out that balance i think it's
going to be
tricky for me
i'll give you one one uh
like basic parenting advice like book
parenting advice which is which has been
very very helpful it would behoove you
to treat your child until
at least he's 17 or 18 as an alien from
another planet
so
don't expect
like rational responses you know don't
don't kill yourself thinking to yourself
that makes no sense why would you say
that why would you do that that makes no
sense at all
because it's not an attitude problem
they literally
don't have fully developed brains
literally
like their brains
don't work like yours
so
when they do things that are absolutely
baffling
in your mind which is a fully developed
brain you're like that is illogical i
can't understand why anyone would do
that well that's because you're talking
to an alien from another planet and if
you
just think of them that way it'll help
you trust me like but like i said like
my son is 17 he's just fantastically
adult and then this morning on his way
out the door to drive to school he's
like oh by the way there's a big uh
exclamation point and a yellow triangle
and the check engine lights on in my car
and it's five minutes until he's
supposed to leave for school
it's like
why did you make that decision to tell
me right then that's not bad behavior
that's not that's not poor behavior
that's just yeah
a malfunctioning brain
yeah
and you just the the quicker you
understand that i trust me it'll save
you so many headaches so many headaches
sam we thank you for calling in for this
fantastic uh question it's been so nice
having you on the show
i appreciate it good luck sam
folks do you want to be like sam come
and ask us your life's big question
parenting advice obviously we got a lot
of that
all you gotta do is go to apple podcast
or wherever you get your
podcasts rate and review the show ask us
your life big question and we might have
you on to ask it of us personally it's
very easy you can also send us your
life's big question you can find us on
social at reza aslan and rayne wilson
you can find us on twitter at
metamilkpodcast and on instagram
metaphysical milkshake and let us know
your life's big question
who knows we just might explore them on
a future episode
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samasa de jazz harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
do octopuses have penises
and if so what would they be called
yeah anyway
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you